en pleine crise sanitaire les tensions
entre états unis et errance poursuivre
deux pays un très durement touchée par
le courant d'un virus après les menaces
de la halle trump contre des bateaux
iraniens téhéran réplique regard des
médias ce qui fit menaces et
intimidations américaine lancement d'un
satellite militaire iranien les
relations entre washington et téhéran ne
semble pas s'apaiser malgré le contexte
d'épidémie
la semaine dernière un accident maritime
survient dans les eaux internationales
du golfe persique et met le feu aux
poudres sur les images des bateaux
iraniens navigue proches des bâtiments
de l'us navy près du koweit le président
américain donald trump réagi dans la
foulée sur twitter j'ai donné pour
instruction à la marine américaine
d'abattre et de détruire tous les
bateaux armés iraniens s'ils harcelé nos
navires en mer la menace ne reste pas
sans réponse du côté de téhéran
les dirigeants iraniens estiment être
dans leurs droits à propos de l'incident
dans le golfe persique et n'hésite pas à
mettre en garde les forces américaines
présentes dans la région
désormais monde d'ailleurs
nous avons en donner à nos unités
navales en mer au cas où des navires de
guerre ou des unités militaires de la
force navale de l'armée terroriste
américaine voudrait mettre en danger nos
navires commerciaux ou le navire de
combat qu'elles doivent viser ses
navires de guerre où ces unités navales
on chez nova lien on ne voit rien et en
mirror nous disons aux américains que
nous sommes absolument déterminés et
sérieux dans la défense de notre
sécurité nationale de nos frontières
maritimes de nos intérêts navale de
notre sécurité maritime et de la
sécurité de nos forces de défense en mer
nous répondrons à toutes actions par une
contre attaque décisive efficace et
rapide at on souligné
parallèlement à cette nouvelle escalade
de tension l'iran a annoncé ce mercredi
le lancement avec succès d'un premier
satellite militaire depuis le désert de
markazi diffusé à la télévision d'état
l'événement a été vécue comme une
provocation par washington
le secrétaire d'état américain estime
que l'iran devra rendre des comptes
à propos de cette initiative en ce qui
concerne l'iran vous avez noté le
lancement hier soir les iraniens n'ont
cessé de dire que ces programmes de
missiles était déconnectée de l'armée
qu'il s'agissait d' entreprise purement
commerciale je pense que le lancement
d'aujourd'hui prouve ce que nous disons
depuis le début ici aux etats unis
le corps des gardiens de la révolution
islamique une organisation terroriste
désigné a lancé un missile aujourd'hui
vous savez que le régime iranien a fait
le tour du monde en diffusant de la
désinformation en réponse à ce virus une
des choses qui l'ont dit c'est que nous
avons besoin de ressources pour nous
occuper du virus chez nous et pendant ce
temps ils lancent des satellites
conduisent des navires dans le golfe
arabo-persique vienne et harcèlent les
navires de la marine américaine
le lancement de ce satellite est jugée
illégale par washington mais téhéran
estime qu'il ne va pas à l'encontre de
la résolution de l'onu sur son programme
nucléaire
face aux accusations des etats-unis
l'iran réaffirme qu'il n'envisage pas de
se doter de l'arme atomique